I think one of the kind of the
resounding messages I hear from CEOs
right now is hey we've got our just
normal business operations that we've
got to worry about make sure our
business is strong and then you layer in
the virus stuff and there's kind of this
health crisis so I want to make sure
that my team is healthy their families
are healthy et cetera but that health
crisis the response globally is now
creating this economic crisis right
where you see the macro economy kind of
slowing down maybe just share your
thoughts on what you're seeing from the
macro economy are you worried about
anything there and kind of how you're
thinking through more of kind of a
response to the virus more so than just
the virus itself sure I think there's a
yeah so that's a pretty so this there's
a lot of aspects to it I think for the
for the balanced team we do we have
asked the balanced team to work from
home way early like so when this thing's
kind of brewing in China I just told
everyone I said look just just work from
home and so I think that was like end of
January early February I just said let's
just work from home and so and our team
is pretty used to it it seems like they
sometimes congregate in a coffee shop or
stuff like that when they're in the city
it's just a less let's just be more
careful about it and and we also measure
our internal employee all the team
members or we call we don't really use
the word increased that much so I also
make sure that we have like we we have
supplies that we secured through various
channels and we measure most of our team
members do have to supplies even our
members right now you are with their
parents spies like masks where they
couldn't get them right now so we so we
took a lot of precaution to ensure
safety of our employees and we all
encourage them to work from home just
don't go out that often and they
typically work from anyway so they're
quite like they quite the very useful
and at a higher level at a bigger scale
in different countries in the world I
think I think this thing's gonna last
multiple months it I think it's gonna
last I think coming summer the virus may
subside but I think we gotta be very
careful if you look at past pa'dar mcc's
there's a very often second wave come
come on
and I think right now we're just with
which we're witnessing this is like a
leadership test for a lot of countries
right so countries who are well
organized even like you look at China
even though you happen earlier there but
they actually had a I think the numbers
may be too low like the numbers may or
may not be accurate but the situation is
that you have it under control
most most guys are returning to normal
the work is returning other countries
are still fighting it and other
countries are still losing the battle
with it or to be honest especially like
America I think the numbers the numbers
the numbers say the results of the
results are there so I think they missed
you at the top stage where we haven't we
haven't seen the plateau so that's very
worrying and I think that would
definitely have an economic I think
we're back in February March people in
some countries or you know United States
some people are saying oh no this
thing's just happening impact in China
nothing's going by the US I think we
live in one global economy there's no
escape so I think we're seeing that
playing out I think it's gonna be
multiple amounts it's gonna have very
severe impact on the economy on jobs etc
so I think we've got to prepare this for
the long run and afterwards I also think
even like after a few months after this
passes we're gonna see a new economy so
things gonna be different people are
people will be the social norms are
gonna be different so I don't know how
different you will be but I think in the
back of people's heads people will I
think even come autumn or the next
winter people will be very cautious
about this thing dependent it depends on
whether we we discover a vaccine or not
so all of those in play play a factor
but most countries are banning travel I
think tribe was gone for the next I
don't know half a year or so to a large
extent so travel within the country may
be allowed by I think people are very
cautious about it
even today so there's a lot of
restaurants are being hit really hard
movies or theaters or hit really hard so
I think a lot of businesses will change
but also in this turbulent environment
there's a lot
opportunity's right so when when one
business unfortunately when one business
goes down other business that's right so
I think online businesses well do well
international business the virtual
aspect of the cryptocurrencies actually
helps a lot
I think cryptocurrency is gonna see a
fairly strong boost to be honest
combined was like quantitative easing
depression like cut the countries have
no other option but you print a lot of
money right now and that's gonna those
money right now is not free flowing into
the economy but once they start flowing
cost of goods most prices are gonna go
up very dramatically and I think
cryptocurrency will go up much more like
on proportionally higher so yeah so I
think all of those things gonna happen
and I think people in the crypto
industry are generally in a very good
spot so I think we just got a I think we
want to we want to work really hard I
think it's actually important to work
really hard in this economic to be
turbulent times because there are new
opportunities and the guys who can grab
these new opportunities are much there's
much more new opportunities
opportunities right now than they were
before I also think most likely more
banks and more financial institutions
are gonna look at cryptocurrency they're
more willing to work with a crypto
currency exchanges payment services etc
so I think there's a lot of opportunity
it's not gonna be easy it's gonna be
tough but yeah you know when when the
going gets tough the tough gets going